ooh is it chilly in here yes why because
hell has frozen over and our studio is
no longer using plastic cups and while
I'm happy for the environment and the
turtles this cup is lame as [ __ ] no
totally oh and good morning good morning
good morning Millennials
good morning plastic straw users good
morning plastic cup users who aren't us
anymore
I used to paper straw yesterday and it
was just not not good I was our original
argument against the war on straws was
like straws are the smallest problem
maybe start with cup right so you know
what this is what should have happened
first and I'm weirdly okay with it I
just wish this wasn't as ugly but I did
hear that they now make plastic made out
of corn and it just looks and feels the
same it's just more expensive to make so
we got to figure that out we definitely
figure that out anyways this cup change
for the is one small step for the toast
one giant leap for mankind
so yeah we're happy to you know be
fighting the war on plastic and Adrian
Grenier you can still grab spoons and
you'd still come on our show and you can
sell them on the show oh wait anyone
come on show even our biggest haters
also checking our both watching on
youtube today I wanted to be on the
premium experience I'm really I'm Pro
YouTube actually Team YouTube I think so
too
like for so many reasons and I've heard
the comments there are premium as hell
and I used to think Facebook comments
were premium is how so if YouTube's even
more premium I just can't even believe
what I'm missing totally the ladies say
that the only issue on YouTube is that
you can't like someone else's comment Oh
which is like you know audience building
community building that's kind of sucks
but I'll live I'll live as well anyways
we have an amazing show for you today
because we have obviously the news you
need to know this morning and it's well
rounded as hell because no celebrity
like news really happened which is
amazing no because Thomas Margo kept his
mouth shut for 24 hours so we can talk
about other things today which is very
exciting she's very exciting and we're
gonna recap action on paradise because
we have so many thoughts so many
thoughts we have a lot of thoughts but
all the thoughts could also be just
summed up into this we haven't done that
in a while okay okay let's sum up our
thoughts on bachelor in paradise oh so
stupid so stupid anyways there's just
like a few housekeeping things that we
need okay first up we have
unbelievably exciting announcement
coming to you on our Instagram today at
noon if you are watching live check our
Instagram at noon if you're listening on
the podcast go wasn't go check our
Instagram now because I'm sure it's
already up
it is everything you've been waiting for
it is what you think it is and we're so
[ __ ] excited and in order to
celebrate I've prepared a song you
believe God is one man thank you thank
you that wasn't what I was expecting I
thought I'm searching a moment like this
maybe where we're at this burns burns
burns burns burns but just to me I mean
my Herzberg burns but just see me do me
mark mark mark mark mark yes that would
also another updating development two
days in a row we have the snitch cam I
can't believe our spoiled interns showed
up two days in a row we're really proud
of her she's out here working with the
headphones we're calm she has a
microphone on can you hear us you're on
the stitch cam smile she's just I'm just
so busy she's so busy working I mean
literally this morning we sent her for
one task get me a cup with a plastic
straw this an intern cannot catch a
break snitch turn this [ __ ] turn mister
cuz snitching doesn't really work it's
like you're not supposed to say the full
word at the beginning you know you know
it's funny so our new hashtag for the
snitch cam is obviously hashtag snitch
cam so I clicked excite was like there's
nothing here and it's like all people
with their friends like being snitches
and I just [ __ ] love the word snitch
me too I love the girl snitch I love
everything about symmetry hashtag snitch
cam 20:18 also Jackie and I were just
discussing an interesting development
when it came to about trim paradise and
Jackie let me know something very
interesting that Becka kouf
I knew the chief out man Instagram I
believe I follow her back she follows
the breath like hey someone has to tell
her and B someone needs to retell her
the new show well here's the thing when
everything happened like she was very
busy on yeah honestly it's very strong
she can have a phone it's a strong
possibility that she don't know she
probably
oh those girls aren't sabbatical they
work so hard totally well I know that
there are Bachelor toasters
they're like no comment on because
Instagram seriously let her know that we
transition we've rebranded to the
morning toast and just add us a million
times please and you guys did it on
everyone know I'm Derek path and let me
ask you did you Bridget Everett you did
really do it it's fine
you didn't Heather McMann we're
reserving your energy be coop we'll give
you two seconds I'll drink my water you
go to Instagram and then come back we
just lost sever viewers because they're
like scrolling on air that was a
terabyte yeah why don't you do that noon
when you're on Instagram for our special
announcement sorry sorry anyways we have
a great show for you today I'm still
shook because last night I saw something
that I couldn't unsee and your man your
man payda hair at Nobu your man made out
with my friend we gotta find that video
I can't believe she did it for us no I
know your man ate a hair at Nobu and I
literally woke up in the middle of the
night laughing about it because let me
tell you it shook me to my goddamn core
it is my worst I mean having hair my
food is like the only thing that can get
me to stop eating and unknowingly and
finding it post meal I mean okay let me
tell you I'm still not over it so me and
Ben like on the weeknights we're very
much of the mindset like as opposed to
like going out to dinner and like
getting home late like we want it we're
both home from work probably around like
six or seven we want to get in bed at 6
or 7 and like eat dinner like to spend
time in bed relaxing but last night I
had a meeting uptown with my friend
Jamie right next to Nobu so I was like
you know what special occasion I love
Nobu like let's just go even though I'm
really anti going out to dinner on the
weeknights like it's just it's not how I
choose to spend my free time I like to
spend my free time in bed not doing like
what you think just like relaxing and so
we go we having a lovely time I ran into
Wilma and Kenny astronaut it was just
like such a classic New York night you
know sorry to sound like Carrie Bradshaw
all he really was a classic New York
yeah so what me and Ben are eating and
Ben always orders many appetizers where
I just have one entree I'm not an
appetizer gal and Ben thinks he's a
foodie I don't know why and he like
takes videos of everything he eats and
you know sees it he doe sees him and he
got all these likes she means everything
and we're outside waiting for a cab when
the meal is over and he's like going
through his GM's cuz you like to see the
response to your your
premium content and literally seven
million people are pointing out this
like curly hair in one of the dishes and
he's freaking out because when we go
back and watch a video like you can't
not see the hair it's like so yeah I
encourage everyone to go to a boy with
no jobs Instagram story at noon
we were dying like it was so crazy like
it was the most I don't know how we
didn't see it was the most visible thing
ever oh my god I I hope that like one
that you save it that you lodge a
complaint and that like someone who has
the powers that be at Nobu like wrongs
rights this wrong no no they care so
wrong no but doesn't respect the toast I
know who doesn't respect the choice but
I think Nobu respects bad press like
this and this is a [ __ ] travesty by
the way you know who does respect the
toast the company that made my daughter
you name plate as you guys know viral
sensation another viral thing happened
coming out from the chest I ordered a
name plate like off of an Instagram and
that I thought was cute it was like Old
English letters all lowercase Claudia
and when I got it it literally spelled
da DIA because the lowercase C attached
to the L is a D and I didn't really want
to blow them up I said their name like
once super quietly on the show I didn't
wanna blow them up cuz like it's like
mean and there's like a nice company and
I ordered it like I didn't make a
mistake like yeah but it was called vibe
season and I ordered it off of Instagram
and they sent me a new two new ones a
girl with no job one and a Claudia with
a uppercase C C nobody you could learn
something yeah Bob Chisholm gives no boo
the day to find out about this atrocity
yeah I'm so I'm so sorry for you and
your family no it was I mean I don't eat
it because I don't eat discussing things
like then so I go home with a man who
realize post meal that he ate a hair and
I'm sorry what's your worst Harry
experience but it comes to food because
I know mine and I'm gonna blow up the
spot I know mine I'm not gonna name the
restaurant because I actually like it as
a place and I don't want to give it a
bad rap but they had a fried what was it
maybe like fried string beans or
something like that just an interesting
fried dish and then I liked
luckily the person or was me who was
eating like was breaking them in half
before eating them not just taking bites
and one of them was just a fried hair
was our son my thing
just
there's two locations in the city and it
was not the location that we've been
together Wow you're not gonna miss a if
you don't know what that sang say it oh
yeah yeah oh my god by the way I had the
most amazing like chicken parm sandwich
there the other like two years ago it
was so good no it's a great place and I
want to encourage people go there no but
sometimes you get a hair I saw two
cockroaches in New York City on Saturday
night and you know what I'm still gonna
go back to that bar my worst hair
experience I'm more than happy to blow
it blow it up because this restaurant
should be closed down by the Health
Department koi Bryant Park and which is
so funny cause when I first came out
when we were in high school it was like
the spot if you couldn't get a table
every celebrity was there right it was
like I remember going there and just
feeling like I was in gossip girl like
it was the coolest restaurant I think
they even went there on Gossip Girl
it was so cool and like it's still
around but it's just like a place where
like business people in the area have
lunch in Bryant Park and people who yeah
and we went and it was just a bad meal
because like the service was so bad it
was so empty like no we couldn't get any
help Ben let's send something back that
had like spicy like Mayo in it he was
like I know my own he's like this Mayo
is bad so I'm like okay and when I go to
a Chinese like a sushi place all I eat
is white rice because I don't really
like sushi I don't like raw fish and I'm
eating white rice and as there's like a
big thing of white rice in my mouth like
I literally pull out a hair it was in my
mouth and I was so furious and I told
the man's and usually it like if it's
like I do understand like sometimes
human error a hair does end up in a meal
and if it's like on the side I can get
past it it's not about the hair it's
about what you do after the hair and
it's how the hair got there and it's
like how deep into food the hair is this
hair was inside a ball of rice like it
was deep and I said something and they
couldn't have cared less
that's not cool see that's what's [ __ ]
up like it's I managed restaurant yes
hairs happen mm-hmm good hair is half
bad hairs happen to good people
totally if I manage rice don't like your
home meal would be comped it's what you
do after the hair that night like in New
York it's just like I can't believe we
live this way sometimes
cockroaches Harry food some restaurants
are really starting to gross me out like
just like being there and
now that's why people say once you work
in a restaurant you can never eat in the
restaurant that's why that's another
reason why I want to learn how to cook
so that I can control yeah my hair like
my favorite restaurant which I know it's
clean it's it's a Michelin star I just I
don't want like main restaurants but
whatever I know it's a it's a clean
restaurant it's like a very fancy sushi
place me and my friends were sitting and
we were sitting like kind of near the
kitchen and had a swinging door and
every time the door swung this like
horrible smell was like breezed in to us
and we were like what the [ __ ] is that
and it's just like everything is so
nasty when I go to a restaurant and they
have those like open kitchen layouts I
can't eat facing the kitchen I can't
look at the kitchen while I eat or else
actually I shouldn't then maybe I would
eat less right but that's why the one
thing I can't see the kitchen while I'm
eating I don't want to know how the
sausage gets made y'all know I'd rather
order in they just it's a mystery you
know the scariest thing and look if you
think you're bringing that hair into
your home right it's your family and
it's not how many things that bag has
been through before it gets to your door
it's like sickening it's it's sickening
and I should just cook but I'm just so
not interested no things are gonna get
bad enough for me soon that one I'm
gonna learn to cook and to I'm moving to
Cleveland
Jackie's obsessed with this concept of
moving to Cleveland it's like I'm always
complaining about New York like after
this uber thing the two cockroaches on
Saturday night really put me over the
edge and I've just been like thinking
and now the hair and now the hair hair
great at Nobu and it's like you're not
even safe at Nobu and I just don't think
that's so true it's the city and if I
want things to change
I must leave the city and like what is a
city in this in this country that like
people that is a good good I'm gonna
wait I'm coming to Cleveland you need to
come with me I am 100% gummy I don't
know what their job com tickets at the
Cleveland Show in October also I'm going
to Raleigh on Thursday snake shook it up
snitch what a girl's own job back home
and look up the date of the Cleveland
Show also I'm going to Raleigh on
Thursday and we added a second show cuz
the first one sold out and then last I
heard yesterday the second show only at
26 VIP tickets left that was it and I
haven't checked so it might be sold out
but if you want to come please let me
know so I'll be moving to Cleveland even
though I've never been I just feel like
LeBron like loves it in trainwreck Liz
Lemon loved it the show Hot in Cleveland
like by the way a smoke
the sodas 30 rock we're Liz Lemon
basically and oh and Chloe Chloe it's
never been happier Betty White October
18th is the date of Cleveland Show so
Jackie's gonna be coming with me I don't
know if she'll be returning with me this
is true also the episode I'm thirty rock
where Liz Lemon moves to Cleveland and
what what makes her move to Cleveland is
this woman and the street spinning in
her honestly 30 is one of the most
underrated shows and I like I hate the
way that they went out because like in
their in their first couple seasons like
they were winning every single Emmy and
then like the fifth or sixth season in
the 60s and they cut it short like
because nobody was watching it like I
hate that it went out that way because I
think it's one of the most in tune shows
not even in tune it's just the one I
like the smartest show but even if you
watch it now you like these jokes could
have been written in 2018 like it's so
relevant Green yeah it's so good it's a
good show to start from the beginning I
started from the beginning now twice had
this conversation many a time okay sorry
always praising 30 back so you guys know
30 rocks what's up
so it's Cleveland see you there soon
it'll just be another cockroach before I
get there anyways are you ready to get
into the Fast Five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast yes I am
thank you for asking first story is
crazy and chugged a veteran woth model
recalls leading kylie jenner's birthday
party on a stretcher dying so you also
the pictures of a girl a blonde woman
face down face down on a stretcher
leading Kylie's birthday and we're all
like who nobody knew who it was who is
she how dare she right into Australian
Instagram influencer Tammy Hebdo has
broken her silence after leaving Kylie
Jenner's 21st birthday party on a
stretcher and being driven to the
hospital in an ambulance hem bro who
previously appeared in one of khloe
kardashian's good american campaigns
recently told a news Australia she had
befriended a few of the famous sisters
quote they're super down-to-earth nice
girls hen bro revealed they're just
normal people like everyone else in a
youtube video published Sunday Hemmer
revealed what led to her early exit from
Jenner's party at Delilah in West
Hollywood last week where guests
included Ashley Benson Chris Brown Dave
Chappelle Jordan Clarkson Cara
Delevingne
Kevin Durant Bella Hadid Carla got
invited Kylie's birthday how I know I
feel like it was a really mixed bag like
I feel like Scott
like Kylie was like bring your friend
like Frank yes it's open yeah
Stas was there French Montana the
weekend in Jordan woods amongst others
quote so firstly I just want to let
everyone know that I'm okay I've had a
lot of Concerned followers messaging me
and asking if I'm just alright so I just
want to clear that up and say yes I'm
okay so basically what happened was I
was in LA I was running off pretty much
30 hours here comes the bit hola here
comes the big lion by the way she's
talking so much slower than this it's an
insufferable do to watch her but we'll
just give you her excuse yeah I was
struggling to stay awake even when I was
getting my hair and makeup down I was
literally sitting there like falling
asleep like I could barely keep my eyes
open I've been throwing myself into work
way more than ever and also I have the
kid my kids the majority of the time she
told her subscribers it's literally been
like a non-stop on-the-go kind of thing
basically she says she's jet-lagged and
she passed out at the party she fell
asleep and they carried her out on a
stretcher totally honestly it's
everyone's favorite excuse of exhaustion
no honestly like there's nothing to be
embarrassed about for like drinking too
much it happens to everyone I'm like if
you'd been more honest like honestly I
would like you more and like I didn't
really realize why she felt the need to
like deliver a statement but then martyr
told me that all the Kardashians
unfollowed her I said well they should I
just like you believe it let's talk
about waking up with a Pitt you get the
golden ticket to Willy Wonka's chocolate
Kylie's Jenner's Factory and like just
and by the way she turned honestly good
first she turned one modeling gig for
good American into like an imitation an
invitation a follow from most of the
sisters like that's impressive and how
it all could just crumble in one night
just think of the you know when you wake
up and like you did something a little
weird then I perform like you've a huge
pit for like two days
imagine the size of the pit this girl
has she lost the kardashians as
followers as friends she probably cover
of the Daily Mail on a stretcher like
stuff she's probably not getting another
good American campaign I can tell you
that much it ain't looking likely it's
not looking likely but honestly she did
it to yourself like you got the golden
take in and you couldn't hold your
alcohol or who even knows what it
actually was she sang Josh Ian were
assuming overconsumption right but it
could have been something entirely
different but if she was exhausted why
would she be face down because she
wasn't because she was sleeping that's
what I was thinking like why would her
shoes off and she had like black thing
like it was just so clearly and like her
hair was a mess it was so clearly like
she's drinking too much or like getting
too [ __ ] up which is like not
deal no but you don't do that at Kylie's
real of course and the Kardashians do
not need that stain like you are now a
stain
I know it's like I think it's a little
harsh of them to just like excommunicate
her but I don't she probably was barely
invited to begin with yes a a girl came
to your birthday party who was like a
friend of a friend or just like but but
they followed her on Instagram so like
okay you haven't like you followed her
and it's ago maybe she has a pop and
Instagram cousin sir she has kids I'm
sure it's all cute goodness and she
comes to your birthday party Nardo
everyone's saying they still follow her
margosa living misinformation he'll
follow her some of them unfollowed her
it's not me it's the morning toasters I
read it there so play God so unreliable
anyway some of them follow her some of
them unfollowed her and you are bringing
the ambulance to Kylie Jenner's birthday
party like she doesn't need that she
just turned 21 yeah there's already like
so much like so many people outside like
it just as chaos don't party hard like
no and they don't came to this Wigga 42
but there was nothing in the bottle was
empty she thought we couldn't see but
the flash reflected and I saw that there
was nothing in that right so that's the
kind of level of partying that they're
doing which is very sweet and innocent
like you don't bring the stretcher dude
they filmed Kylie's birthday she's so
weird she's like not on the show and
they usually don't film during the
summer because last season started
filming in October right but I don't
think they're airing now so I don't know
a missed opportunity if you ask me yeah
but then they filmed Kendall's birthday
last week and there was nothing there
just a few miramare pictures like but
you know Mir Mir that with a shark they
were on shark tank that photobooth
company that does all the Kardashian
eventually makes I'm also like pretty
and skinny and my friend Marco had her
wedding and it was so epic like no one
there like got it do you know what I
mean they didn't get a deal and Robert
had them at their wedding and they like
what you've literate we've had this
conversation literally word-for-word
honestly maybe it's not not that I have
dementia maybe that we do this show all
the [ __ ] time and I only have lived
24 years so like I don't have that much
to talk about but we do but it's just if
you watch you should put one episode
next to the other thing you talk about
Robert I mean it's an affliction I
shouldn't be laughing
yeah there's a spec I read that -
there's speculation that Cara Delevingne
and Ashley Benson are dating so her
being there would make sense as Cara
Delevingne state not really as a guest a
plus-one kinds of friends friends of
friends everyone's welcome
everyone's welcome it was like I guess
it must have been like hundreds of
people yeah I mean they closed down the
restaurant which I've been to it's huge
good for that in the ball pit did you
see the outside like she covered the
actual facade of the building and like
pink sparkles that's amazing it was so
cute that's the way to go I'm just glad
that they're like spending their money
wisely and having the parties that they
deserve totally and like it's more
special like we have parties all the
time so like it's just another party but
like they never party so like excuse me
everyone getting together for this one
night and like they all commit it like
it all drink they all dressed up like
they all went a hundred percent for
Carly and I appreciate that and that's
because they do it so infrequently right
but Kim still woke up early the next
morning and worked out which was just
like not cool
I'm just unrealistic yeah like no like
you can work out the next morning party
to wake up early right I guess the kids
they go to school it was like the
weekend no the parties on a Thursday
night hmm I don't know why I feel like
it's famous kids don't go to school I
know but then when I only thought that
was the most recent episode she was like
and then I had to pull my kids out of
school go to school totally memory Kylie
and Kendall were like on their way to
their midterms and like Kylie got out of
the car and like was crying and I'm like
Kris let her go home like if I ever did
that get to school [ __ ] like what is
like that life is not real and then they
like hired this like homeschooling
company behind Chris's back and had them
like me in the living room so weird and
they like couldn't handle like all their
extracurriculars like cheerleading and
traveling right and by the way that was
like when they weren't even working they
were like creative directors for
Seventeen magazine that was like the
most work they had Kendall wasn't even a
model right so crazy but I mean they did
everything right yeah and then they had
that weird graduation party with like
Ryan Seacrest
remember yeah and Chris is like entry
yeah imagine make such a big house a
your entryway is big enough for a
graduation ceremony oh man
okay ready for next story oh wait check
it - summer they're not in school
sorry we're done but they probably a kid
like that mean
going around it's like went back to
school commercials are airing but you're
not a teacher or student so you don't
care that was like the biggest seeing
those commercials all this reading all
this was like the sunday of months you
know summer reading I mean you said it's
just thinking about summer we said those
math packets that you have to do oh my
god
torture yeah okay okay I want to see
something really interesting
please so I went through 12 grades four
years of college and endless reading
assignments and I think it's very
important for everyone to know that I
got by and I only did I swear on my life
I read one of those books and one of
those readings the book I only read was
a curious instead of the dog in the
middle the night because like I don't
know there was a picture of a dog on it
and I just like felt like reading it oh
and that was this summer I went to
Seneca and like all my friends in my
bunk went to my school too so like they
were reading it I was like okay I
already too but that was the only time
in college reading assignment I never
did one reading assignment even for the
midterm I never read and like yes I
wasn't like a straight-a Honor Society
student but I made it out alive and I'm
fine and I think you're more than my
year because use morning shows right so
I think it's important to know for
anyone who's like watching this in the
library like stop doing the reading like
someone wrote a summary of it online
reading is useless I'm done with reading
I never really started but I'm done I
just think it so interesting I've never
ever ever read a book that I was
assigned in school like Hamlet like I
know what it's about he wanted to [ __ ]
his mom but I never read it Romeo and
Juliet never read but like I know
Montagues and the Capulets you know they
mean yeah is it crazy that is really
like I've never read an important piece
of literature because I just didn't want
to in school but I know all about it
Midsummer Night's Dream Hamlet the Iliad
and the Odyssey I don't know I I didn't
have the readings probably because
that's really all cuz you're a nerd no
cuz I'm a slow [ __ ] actually my fast
reader expense from reading Gossip Girl
I'll read it in 20 minutes if I'm
reading The Iliad and Odyssey like I
can't even get through a paragraph what
is that
if you're this it's dense it's like I
can't understand what I'm looking at I
could read the same line over and over
again and then not tell you what I just
read and I know we're getting like a
huge pitch to some of our younger
listeners who are like probably pushing
off procrastinating their summer reading
don't do it here's the thing that if
you're pushing out for castings are mean
the only reason why you should do
is to absolve the pit other than that
you don't need to do it that's true
you'll get back but like weathering
Heights the trees were like penises I
don't know it just reading is so stupid
like you've read a book like Dorian Gray
like that's a good but totally but like
I feel like literature and like English
classic is unrealistic like so okay
Wuthering Heights there were these trees
and his trees would sing cuz they
breathe so much and it was like a
metaphor for like sex or something like
you're like looking for things that
don't exist
hey how do you know that's what how do
you energy the author really wanted like
you to think that the trees were penises
and be like that's just sets a bad
precedent for like how to live your life
like just not taking things at face
value you know and like not living in
reality like everyone says that
Shakespeare said all this stuff like
between the lines but he really just
said what he was saying and if he wanted
to say something else wouldn't he upset
it I remember in like English class
everyone would always like come up with
these alternate meanings for what was it
was more wild it was the better your
grade wise so I remember one time
specifically the teacher we were reading
The Great Gatsby and what's-her-face the
annoying grows a pixie cut goes over to
Gatsby's house and it's like looking at
all his closet and all of his silk
shirts and she starts crying and the
teacher was like why is she crying and I
was like you know what I'm just gonna
like say the most outlandish um I was
like Jackie she's crying because she's
thinking of all the children in
sweatshops who worked so hard to make
these shirt it's no way did you say
thanks where and what they said no of
course not that's like always they don't
know why she's crying right now and I
just I think it's a bad way to live your
life and it's a poor way of like being
grown up to think because like now we're
looking for meaning and everything when
like sometimes things are just face
value and like that's it however but the
Torah is a lot of interpreting what
right the Torah like the Bible is like
this mystical you're supposed to take
extract meaning from your life from it
it's spiritual
I don't extract meaning from my life
from [ __ ] Dorian Gray there's a
difference there is a difference because
also the tour isn't meant like William
Shakespeare never sad read I know God
was like here's this book take what you
want from it learn what you want from it
it can mean there's nothing wrong on it
with the time there's nothing wrong in
interpreting the Bible like it's
everyone's interpretation is correct
there's a man's room
there's nothing incorrect there is
something incorrect in thinking that
Hammett wanted to [ __ ] his mom maybe he
did it by the way literally I was
sitting at lunch with Margo when we were
in West Palm Beach and she goes randomly
out of nowhere she goes well
Shakespeare's first name that's right I
couldn't stop staring at her she could
hear that like 10 seconds later but I
was like okay reading is novel I'm
actually when I go away next week I want
to get a really good book and see if I
can get this mission to law a
substantive I don't want to get like
endless love I want to get a substantial
book maybe like like Anna Karenina oh my
god that is so much space in your
suitcase
and we're expanding our minds every day
now talking about like what else is
going on but I feel like I could expand
my mind even more if I just read
something that I would never read no
good for you honestly I feel like you
know how to make me so tired and dizzy
like every time I read a book that isn't
like a tell-all by celebrity I fall
asleep right it's just not for me but
there's just no good celebrity tell else
anymore that's why I'm yeah where's
Triana crew I just think there's like a
stigma around like people who don't read
aren't smart and I just want you to know
if you don't like to read and you think
it's boring you could still be smart
like look at me I'm gonna a Peabody
award-winning morning shows and I
literally have never read a full book in
my life I could name probably five whole
books I've read three Andy Cohen's and
honestly and then finishes the third one
it was just like I never got to it I
finished in one of Chelsea Handler's
books this curious tale the Curious
Incident oh a couple of the a-list
series when we were in very order in the
whole a list series those were great I
make sure I don't think they would be as
good reading as an adult because they're
about high school students and we're
reading them as middle schoolers being
oh my god this is so silly sheis and
like yeah but now I'd be like who are
these kids like if I read the click now
reading about 8th graders I hope I did
we the click and fold like I don't I
don't really can't remember the last
time I read a full book that wasn't
written by celebrity and that's okay I'm
done with like this stereotype surrounds
like people who don't like to read you
could be cool and funny and smart and
still not like to read that's fair yeah
[ __ ] that I think school and not reading
at school I was loved reading a magazine
I mean I actually can't I don't like
reading love but it actually took the
advice of its some toasters and got the
People magazine crossword mega book like
just that only has crosswords because
that's really why I buy magazines and
airports since
much money at Hudson news and not having
to buy and I'm really enjoying it except
it's super hard but I'd like to be
challenged that's what my friends read
so much and they're always talking about
like the new books that they read it's
really they're like Dana probably we
reads a book a week she's ready
everything under the Sun and then they
they they're so like now that he think
about it they're like so they're always
no baby they're nerdy and like they're
always just talking about like the new
books oh my god this one was Jackie
they've read everything that would be a
great time to make a friends reference
that you don't know so Joe they're all
like super smart Joey's like so dumb to
the point where it's not believable
that's like a problem I have with the
show but like a traveling salesman comes
to his door he said would you like to
buy an encyclopedia and he's like I'm
how many money and the guys like do your
friends talk about things you have no
idea what they're talking about he's
like yeah so he buys this one and
memorizes it it's live a letter v he
could only afford one and he starts
talking about like did you guys hear
about this volcano this eruption and
they're like yeah and they're also he's
finally a part of it and then someone
changes the subject of something with
like a K it's like no it's great that's
funny
yeah maybe you should watch it I like
your recaps better than okay fine I
agree okay next story while we're only
on story number two in some o'clock
Google tracks you even if location
history is off reports wired we were
talking about this with Ben the other
day because Apple was saying they don't
record you but Google does track you if
like most people you thought Google
stopped tracking on location once you
turn off location history in your
account settings you were wrong
according to an AP investigation
published Monday even if you disable
location history the search giant still
attracts you every time you open Google
Maps get certain automatic weather
updates or search for things in your
browser there's a way to stop it but it
takes some digging
the problem with techs anyone with an
Android phone and iPhone users running
Google Maps on their device is according
to the AP report which researchers at
Princeton University verified that's
more than 2 billion people ok but I just
say like something controversial like I
don't really care if people know about
my location do you know anything like
I'm not embarrassed of my my history
that I go to work and I stay at home in
bed like you know what I mean yeah
unless they're like giving that
information to other people which I
don't think they are this doesn't bother
and like in a pinch right could save
your life
what freaks me out is like when they
hear me talking like just to another
human being do you know any like the
Alexa thing this to me doesn't alarm me
it isn't alarming no I've always said
I'm really ok with the government like
spying on us as long as they're not
gonna use that information to like a
arrest me or be embarrass me do you know
any mean it's MRSA
right so like if they're gonna record me
talking [ __ ] about people and then like
blast it right like that that's not cool
but if you want to record my location
and then maybe in a pinch like I go
missing and you find me like I'm cool
I'm done with that okay but say they
record your location and now they're
selling that information they're selling
your information to like advertisers in
the area that they know that you're in
together you in the store great I'd love
to be served ads that I need like
there's nothing worse in seeing an ad
for like a vitamin supplement I'm never
gonna take it you're gonna store in a
town that you're not in right or postman
you want to do it for post mates great I
actually need that yeah there's nothing
wrong with targeted advertising also
speaking of me going missing have you
heard about Somali Tibbets thing no oh
my god so and you know it's so weird
I get tagged in things on Twitter all
the time like like oh my friend went
missing when you share this poster and I
always share it it's like really social
media can help save lives and I shared
this one a while ago this super cute
girl from Iowa and I just always assumed
that like they resolved that like that
it gets resolved and it hasn't been
resolved and it's like so creepy and
there's this like psychic on reddit who
like predicts like she's gonna know what
happens and something's like supposed to
happen soon and it's like so sad her
family has been out looking and they
found they found a girl and it was like
an another missing girl in the family
thought it was gonna be Molly it's like
so sad so I'm just like keeping up with
it now and if you live in Iowa it's
Brooklyn Iowa a little confusing but if
you live in Iowa her family's been like
non-stop searching for her like they
literally haven't been home in a month
when people go missing it looks weeks me
the earth is only so big no and like
when you hear these stories and like you
get all the facts it's like oh so she
disappeared through the walls but no I
literally just got the biggest pit in my
stomach like where'd you get both of
people like go missing the minute never
to be found or heard from again
room the lovely bones that should be a
movie of the week yeah because Stanley
Tucci is such a good actor yeah that's a
really good movie that we have long
lists okay hold them actually we were
writing down our list I am writing it
down that movie is and by the way you
know it's so funny about that movie the
main character is Saoirse Ronan
I know it was before she became like
famous in Brooklyn in Brooklyn Iowa okay
let me write it down okay and then I
gotta tell you my story
nobody knows
okay we have good ones coming up okay
are you ready for the next door you
ain't sure because it's more on uber
which is just taking over the whole
conversation these days surely it's
dominating the narrative I'd say okay
uber drivers are taking riders the long
way at Huber's expense quote long
hauling is among tactics used by ride
hailing drivers to maximize the fare in
the battle over pay when ferrying
passengers to and from Phoenix Airport
uber driver were you in the zubur
Michelle blondie had a decision to make
well let me think let me think oh no
they sent me Akane oh my god in order to
read the full story I have to subscribe
or sign in does anyone have a wall
street journal login are they kidding oh
my god I'm sorry
anyone who pays for like a subscription
to a magazine on I mean a newspaper
online is a big loser totally like you
can get them for free in the trash wait
okay this is the this is the summary of
the article from me Gina which is a
subscription that I enjoy some unburn
lyft drivers are taking passengers on
the long route in order to drive up
fares but unlike taxis the extra cost is
passed on to Oberer and lyft not the
passengers it's the latest sign of the
sour relationship between drivers and
the companies they're driving for so
that's why I've been saying that this is
happening that someone at uber is like
twinkling with the GPS to make us just
go out of our way for the fun of it and
then I go home and I report of course
extra-long ride and then uber adjusts to
adjust to pay by two dollars anyways and
now I know I'm not crazy
well at least like I don't know there's
like a countability like when you're in
a yellow cab like they could take you
whatever way they want and like the and
that you just have to pay and like you
can't call anyone and complain like at
least with uber they have like a
document a digital map of like the route
that they took you and you can be like
hey look this makes no sense we should
have gone this way it could have saved
five dollars and then they give you the
$5 back so it's like it's a lose-lose
for everyone but I like that uber comes
with like a sense of accountability I
agree but I feel like these days cab
drivers like don't do that anymore
because they're just like so happy for
the business yes I agree unless you like
look like a major tourist and like you
could stand to take the scenic route but
at the same time like now the government
is taking down the wages of many many
ruber drivers so like yeah they're gonna
make the ride longer they need the money
like I don't really blame them I don't
blame them either
we've been they've been forced to do
this
sitting along override with AC than in
the cab like sweating it out putting my
head out the window like a dog literally
I am Pheo in a taxi being in a taxi with
app in the summer it's just like in it's
fun pleasurable experience I hang my
head out the window people think I'm
nuts and I literally like stick my
tongue out it's so hot it's terrible and
like they're they want the cities has
made this rule because they want you to
take more yellow cabs but like the
yellow cabs don't deserve to be taken
they did not evolve with the times
including air conditioning which is just
like a fundamental basic right basic
human right I couldn't read more
couldn't agree more
it's infuriating I listen to God as a
woman like before I came here like now
it's just stuck in my head it's such a
good song it is I honestly haven't had
the pleasure of enjoying it very I
watched the music video again like
knowing what the song is about
it's very salacious all but like it's
just about like it's basically like I'll
[ __ ] you so good you'll think God is
woman Oh
because only a woman can make you feel
that way I heard art vandal a directed I
heard that too she like fingers the
universe she watch it okay I will and I
should listen to the song info' I
stopped really catching up on new music
cuz now it's just like I want to listen
to the music I want to listen to yeah
I'm looking forward to certain albums
coming out but until then I listen to
what I'm being told to listen to you
know I'm here thirsting for new music I
mean it there there's a good stuff out
there but I just love watching ariana
grande saying like I think she really is
like the vocalist of our time of our
generation I think like of the girls who
are popping right now like the biggest
stars in the world I think she's the
most vocally talented and Demi Lovato
yes I think Ariana's better I think
they're both great why do we have to put
them against each other oh god okay
Gloria Steinem over here I'm not I'm
just saying one's better than the other
and my opinion against each other
putting them in a job ring to fight me
next story is so crazy
today's supreme drop is all over the New
York Post a dramatic cover ad on the New
York Post for the street wear company
supreme turn today's tabloid into an
impossible to find commodity so
basically the New York the cover of the
New York Post today is just a supreme ad
those yes sir
yes yeah Monday it's just a supreme ad
and like it's just their logo it says
New York Post and a big old supreme and
[Music]
are sold out and people are like
reselling them for ten times the price
weed right now it's ten dollars but like
we gotta get our hands on one and save
it I know we got a rummage to the trash
like this time old lady who didn't know
what she had you know rush hour
commuters were hard pressed to find a
copy of the New York Post near Port
Authority Bus Terminal and Times Square
on Monday the Hudson book sellers on the
ground floor was sold out of the tabloid
so was the basement kiosk another around
the corner was sold out by 7:15 a.m.
that is so crazy how you ever wonder
about the newspapers selling out right
and how much does it cost to take an ad
on the front page of the New York Post
because I would like to inquire for the
morning don't but it's like this paid
for it's not like New York Post got all
this money only got this paid for itself
and then the supreme stock is just
rising supreme is like so rich I know it
like I don't know do own and I mean
zakho and supreme staff loves it do you
own anything
uh no but I do it's just so funny cuz
when we were in high school it was like
this little store hole in the wall that
likes old skateboards like these boys my
grade looks go to Supreme I'm like you
don't even ask a pro and now it's like
this multi-billion dollar bracket I'm
Louis Vuitton it's so crazy and like the
resale on supreme is like triple it's
insane good for them and like that is
just an exercising branding that it's
just obviously it's obvious that someone
who does the branding for supreme is in
tune with what's necessary and that's
really the key to a successful brand I'm
sorry oh my god I'm so sorry
brand success being in tune ah but I
just think this is so so interesting
it's like so New Age and then old school
newspapers are selling out what yeah and
the group someone's trying to get us to
pay for Wall Street Journal online ha ha
laughter that's the juxtaposition of
today's show so true papers Wall Street
Journal New York Post is selling out to
the supreme honestly I love the New York
Post covers I think they're always funny
and I like that they're like a reverent
but I would like really never forget
them forgive them for what they did to
Kim I think that was so me and Trump
meets Rumph kim kim sungon like she was
just gonna help and she did oh oh yeah
and she did yeah they owe her an apology
a lot of talk all long pause no answer
so right now the copies of the Magna of
the newspaper cover are selling for $12
on eBay but like that's gonna go up and
also that's 12 times what they think
about a paper cost like 75 cents how
much does the paper costs these days a
dollar fifty well that's so crazy
because
literally back in the day a nickel a
nickel but I do think that a newspaper
is the cheapest thing you can buy do you
think what is what can you buy $4.99
actually I'm mom yeah and look not an
incense store even though like Tyler had
it down a meal on the dollar menu yeah
even though with tax it's a little bit
more but like nothing on like the dollar
store is actually a dollar it's just
like cheaper that's an interesting point
you raise interesting point you raised
as well sister yeah I think the
newspaper is the cheapest thing you
could buy it with the most value not
really because it has no value in 24
hours it's literally useless for sure
but people have their dogs go [ __ ] on a
gumball in in 20 minutes
right it's literally disappeared yeah I
understand I understand yeah okay then
final story so crazy from time money
these are the 25 best colleges I thought
we were doing Azealia oh [ __ ] [ __ ] the
colleges oh wait the new college right
well a new couch drinking came out and I
just there's always college rankings and
they're all wrong okay old schools are
bad don't go to school I want you the
other story yeah yeah sorry I just there
were so many stories that I forgot that
we had the Holy Grail thanks Elon Musk
crimes saga and most of you probably
heard about it we'll run it down and I
feel like Azealia Banks it's always
starting unnecessary drama
but like this one is very necessary and
super interesting rapper
Azealia Banks claims she was at Elon
Musk's house over the weekend as he was
quote scrounging for investors the
rapper Azealia Banks claimed that she
spent the weekend at Elon Musk house
setting social media ablaze thanks to a
business insider she saw the Tesla CEO
at home scrounging for investors after
tweeting last week about plans to take
Tesla private banks also said that she
was not trying to eavesdrop but that she
could hear that he was scrambling
because he in fact didn't have any
funding secured so she did like a crazy
rant on her Instagram story like ten
stories basically saying that like
Grimes flew her out to LA to stay at
their house and like he and Grimes and
musk were like tripping acid the whole
weekend and Elon tweeted something
really stupid and when he was coming
down from the acid he like was so upset
that he tweeted it and she was consoling
him the whole time and basically like
got her a ticket home and like didn't
even say bye he's got as a Lea ticket
home cuz she had to consult Elon Musk an
azalea was pissed and like trapped in
the house yeah an azalea was there like
the whole weekend and like nobody even
spoke to her and she was just like he's
dropping on
ilan like being freaks and that he only
is with Grimes because he needed a date
for the Met Gala to protect his
shrinking dick from ever heard dead
first of all the Shah today then wait
Diplo tweeted like this is amazing like
recapping azalea's thing and she screech
out in his tweet and was like shut up
who only 40 grabbed oh my gosh she's
blowing up everyone's fun and I think
like she's really so destructive like
some of the things that she posts are so
crazy and like so defamatory but this
one I'm living for you think it's all
for real yes but some of the [ __ ] she
said in the past like she just says to
get and like she says horrible things
about people and this one is actually
important I believe that young asked
does a say because I feel like all these
like creatives you know it's and opens
up your mind yeah but I can't believe
Elon Musk is stupid enough to tweet on
acid no I can't like he's stupid enough
to do it in front of is Elia banks who's
like the rat of Hollywood she tells
everyone everything right it doesn't
have like people who work for him no
Elon Musk ever since the Thai boy thing
like he is crumbling yeah and that's
exactly what he's saying like he says
like shits going down and like there's
been a crack in the whole empire and
it's like it's starting to crumble I
don't believe it I'm sorry
this is wild and they'll love Elon when
I think of the Azealia Banks like
trajectory career like she started off
with that song I mean the two one two
right it's such a good sorry is that
from playing right yeah like it's the
and she was like really this
up-and-coming rapper and then she like
just couldn't keep her mouth shut it was
like saying crazy things and now like
nobody takes her seriously but now she's
in the news again because one of the
things she said is actually interesting
I mean it's unbelievably interesting
anything with you on is interesting to
me and also like his relationship with
Grimes is I don't know they were still
together and like they live together so
he only brought her to the mecca as his
date to piss off Amber Heard but now
they're living together I guess and they
brought Azalea under the pretense of
recording a song with Grimes cuz
apparently he loans a huge fan of Xillia
what even just continues to surprise me
totally she's imagine getting a call me
like hey this is Elon Musk my girl
foremost record a song with you gonna
come stay at her house for the weekend
and even if I saw the craziest things
and even if they were so mean to me I
would not blow them up because I would
just want to be invited back again right
just
like one Tesla or like one flying car
just one time and then we're square
yeah your secret is safe with me that's
what you'd like me to be our friend like
yeah we're just a treasure trove of
information totally anyways is it time
to about recap bachelor in paradise I
guess so
bachelor in paradise episode 2 aired
last night moving very very slowly
considering I was told there was a ton
of footage from the sea totally I
watched without watching the first
episode because it's really not that
difficult to to catch up I mean they
really explained things for you because
everyone the show talks to you like
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and they look
explain things to you as you're watching
them or like I know what's happening so
I really caught up relatively quickly
and I was so just like you know yeah and
I'm just like this Tia Colton's
storyline it's so unclear what's what
happened in real life it's so unclear
what happened on the show they don't
tell you anything they edited so poorly
and they don't tell you what really
happened
before they got to Mexico I couldn't be
less interested I so don't care anymore
like honestly before the episode I
thought Colton was the hottest thing
since sliced bread and then after
watching him like cry and fold like a
[ __ ] I was like you well know before
from last week's episode I was like
Colton is a fuck-boy he came to paradise
he's leading Tia on and I'm not here for
it but then after this episode I was
like first of all he told her if he was
honest as [ __ ] with her I want to see
other people I don't want you to see me
doing it I don't care that you could
kiss Chris go do your own thing like
spelled it out there and right before
the rose ceremony was willing to go home
in order to not date TIA that girl you
have all the information the problem
with bachelor in paradise is just that
like girls think guys are dicks when
they're just not interested like not
everyone's gonna like each other like
that's not the problem and he was at
least up front with you to be like you
don't have to give me your rose I'm not
here to really date you exclusively I
just got out of this Becca thing and I
want to have fun and like she just
couldn't process that and she was taking
that as him being a dick when he wasn't
being take he was at least being honest
no and he could've easily just said what
she wanted to hear or not even said what
she wanted hear it just like continue to
say a lot of nothing right get the rose
and then turn around when he has the
power right so like I had a lot of
respect for him for being willing to
leave at any moment a gray doesn't need
to be on
like he's fine and I guess I didn't keep
up with Becca season enough to know that
if they actually had a legit
relationship I assume they didn't he was
really just going through the motions to
get to paradise with Fleur become the
bachelor like option crying like that
when he saw Becca just gave me like like
such a pit for him and I don't know if
he's like truly in love with her but
like no one acts like that when it's
someone that you don't care about and
they weren't there's nothing you've been
bad to say about him because nothing's
really happened yet yeah I don't know he
was just like making me really sad and
if I were one of those girls who was
interested in him when he was sitting
alone on the beach it's like that's when
you go up to him and you're like I'm
here for you he felt so alone yeah he
had literally oh my god my guys are such
losers well that's what I was saying on
my story last night it's like the reason
why this season stinks so far is like
all the girls are great and pretty much
marriage material we have so many like a
list girls there agree be Tia Astrid I
could go loving me some Annalise she's
totally a toaster Oh totally except like
she went for Jordan and these guys are
d-list like they're terrible losers not
one of them is marriage material or even
like close to and accept you would have
thought Colton but he's like a young
virgin and does about what Chris is
literally the definition of a little
[ __ ] like he's such a loser there is a
special place in hell for guys that talk
[ __ ] about other guys like get a life
like I hate when guys got to be so
unattractive
Chris is such a [ __ ] loser and his
chosen Thursday yeah why are they coming
in acting like Tia should be so grateful
to be going out with him when he's and
the who saw her no and him acting like
he was his first what's Tia's first
choice like dude have a little self
esteem like Tia literally just got
dumped and now she's just like relying
on you because she need someone to give
a rose to like cotton and Chris is the
thought boy because he did tell Tia
everything she wanted to hear to get her
rose and then we see next we keep
something up with other girls so he
meant none of that so if anything I'm
even like more teen Colton just for the
honesty even if I don't agree with what
he's saying he's like being real and
then a lot of people including myself
were anointed Bibiana for giving her
rose to Colton because I really wanted
this ti Colton saga to [ __ ] end and
the only way that would be is if you
left but a two things one it's so
obvious that production made her do it
and two but you pointed out is that
Mecca was all of this happens they make
it
like it's week-by-week it was two days
no ceremony was on the second night like
this is still fast Becca was in a
[ __ ] hotel room down the street
waiting to come and talk to Colton so if
they send Colton home that night but why
is Becca gonna come and stir [ __ ] up
makes no sense
so also even if production didn't tell
baby on it and like I have to believe
that they did but maybe I don't know
she's hilarious I thought it was
hilarious and funny and also Colton does
deserve club he was at least being
honest
anyways all the guys are really really
trash and all these girls are having to
like I hate what make that happen
they're trying to make that chopping
like analyse in Jordan what trying to
pretend like they're gonna get engaged
at the end of this are you for real also
like Ashton and Kevin are the most
good-looking couple I've ever seen he's
the hottest guy in our nation but the
other couples cuz I'm actually more
interested in them I'm so done with back
with Colton and - yeah like I don't care
Colton pisses me off honestly I wanted
Angela to give Colton her Rosie we're
having Q conversation no but like good
for Angela for not being a loser like
just giving a tip because T it doesn't
give it's him and you know what I mean
no but like he's interested in her yeah
he's like I don't know what he is every
day I can't tell if he's the most
sincere person and it's just being
manipulated or is like the sleuthy guy
who GM's everyone I think he's somewhere
in between and the other thing is the
guys are all acting like he's the
villain he's being ostracized but we
know that he's like good friends with
the guys from his season and like the
cool ones like Blake and wills who went
home way too early he was actually a
real contender but by the way when he
was in the car talking to the camera he
was mumbling I didn't understand a
single thing he said I've literally
wanted I was like what are you saying I
think he needed to stay longer like I
feel like he is a legit guy yeah
wait I want to talk about Kendall
taxidermy and Joe grocery store because
I know you think she's an actress and I
agree but she's in her interviews she's
literally reading from a script but I
think they're actually kind of cute I
think he's definitely hot and underrated
and when she was like right before the
rose ceremony they're just sitting and
she's like that's a reference from the
House Bunny yeah I just thought was
funny that's funny but it's because she
was studying up on all these scripts she
yeah I mean all the line no I'm not mad
about her and Joe if they if they're
like stable good for them yeah and I
feel like they are but it's like
everyone's like Christie stuck
Jojo it's like why because everyone on
Twitter is like Christie sir Joe we
don't know [ __ ] about him every time he
opens his mouth he really has nothing to
say he is an annoying accent but I do
appreciate him just like they're in a
cast like that then you'd see people who
are like out there it's their storyline
but then there also needs to be like an
Izzy and Vinny like just a stable and I
just want to know who that is
they're not gonna make it forever but
just join the herd I start only hooking
up with each other I think it's Kevin in
action Astrid is so pretty like never
saw her on her season no she's so pretty
any time she's caught speaking she's
getting the best advice Kevin is so hot
I just like can't get over like him and
Ashley but it's like I've ever watched
them so I don't even think about her
when I think about him and he's easily
the hottest guy in paradise Chelsey it's
just like with this guy who I've
literally never seen before in my life
John the Ben Joe guy yeah but she didn't
give him her rose chicken I don't know
there's like a little of like people
that I just don't bother no in their
name is Jordan and their fight like are
you for real this is this is original
cast that you're gonna give us this an
original cast these two annoyances
that's like weak for drama yeah that's
not a original house is supposed to be
like legit guys and also where's Connor
our favorite toaster totally also I just
think it's so funny to reflect on the
times like remember when zack kalter was
on bachelor in paradise and Clare liked
him and he didn't like her back like
that was such an epic season and like
just to see even with Carly she was
annoying but like on her first time like
she was so great like Marcus and Maisie
whatever the names are they see that was
just like an epic era of apps from
Paradise and to see how far we've fallen
is really sad and I'm saying it's
because the guys are not up to snuff and
the girls are and it's just like we're
trying to make fetch happen here and
none of these girls won and I are these
guys why would they they know that
they're just like thirst-trapping-- on
Instagram like you look at one
inspirational quote they post on
Instagram and like you are turned off
no they're literally like women that's
an insult to women no and like even like
crystal who is like the craziest girl
like she's killing it I'm loving her and
I also I'm here for her and Kenny
because like he needs a really strong
woman because he has like a 20 year old
daughter and I am I couldn't agree more
I love crystal and you know what I'm
starting to do
I'm starting to judge my own decisions
of people like my own opinions of people
not based on what editing wants me to
think like they wanted me to hey crystal
you know what now I'm gonna like her
they want us to hate Jordan the male
model so far I know next week he hasn't
done anything wrong he's a nice guy we
mother met him he literally couldn't
have been nicer I'm done listening to
what the editors and the producers tell
me to think of people like I will now
form my own opinions short in the male
model has always said funny [ __ ] and
kept the show interesting and if
anything the chicken David is the one
constantly instigating him being
annoying little [ __ ] and I know but also
really good friends with him which like
makes me feel like maybe he's a good guy
cuz I just like love everything that she
does but he's annoying me when me and
Margo saw him I was like Joey and like
show me a pose and he did a pose and it
was actually really good okay it's not
easy like I'm just saying I don't I and
people like you believe you're hanging
out with Jordan like he's some sort of
devil like he is what they made him like
he's that's how who he is like I don't
believe what producers tell me anymore
like I will form my own opinions knowing
what I know about production knowing
what I see about people on social media
and then I will move forward okay great
also I do think Colton's gonna go home
because from all the previews there's
not much more footage of him other than
him crying good this is so she yeah I
think and I think he should go home and
then that would open the door for him to
be the bachelor and I know Margo's
really upset because and she unfollowed
him even though he's her Margo you
unfollowed him I've been talking so much
[ __ ] about him like I know he's gonna
unfollow me he just followed me but like
I don't care I'm really done with him
unless he's a bachelor and then I'll die
I don't think so either
well what is your going we're shipping
you off yes and you're gonna do field
research for the show Margo you got to
delete that before anyone can get it
back up totally no I'm just I'm really
ready to move on to a brand new
storyline I'm really ready for new guys
who are worthy of these girls time and
even like someone like Erik who actually
is legit we never see him he was number
three Rachel season ready to propose
such a nice guy where is he totally this
is just so stupid like I I'm I'm doing
it for the I just want everyone to know
like I watched two hours of pure trash
last night for you I do not enjoy this
and I'm definitely going to get to a
point where I'm no longer watching but I
will to continue to do it while I have
the time
so what it's on again tonight two hours
of one's two hours it's four hours a
week but at least last season it was one
hour tonight and then the after show I
think it now it's just two hours
no after show I know I'm sorry sister
and it's like how dumb do they think we
are like the Sun is literally rising as
Colton's like sweating to see if he's
gonna get a rose and they're like this
week has been amazing
literally you got there yesterday like
how dumb do they think we are there and
the answer is very what's wrong why
don't why don't they take them there for
eight weeks real [ __ ] would happen only
so much can happen when you like someone
yesterday you like them the next day
like it's so stupid it's middle school
it really is and wait and then Becca
coming look I just have to say it's so
funny how like all these people who
signed up for the show are literal
nobody's like they're just regular folk
and then once I get to paradise they're
all they're all equal but then like
Becca Katz Theramore just opposed to
think she's like better than everyone
it's like seeing a celebrity it's like
seeing it like someone higher up like
it's just so good it's all so arbitrary
because there's like she weren't hot
weren't made the Bachelorette and she
was just on that beach like everyone
there would be treating her like
everyone else but you try shirt right so
I just think it's so funny how like one
thing happens I'm like you're different
now
you happen though they're all relatively
the same they're nobodies from all over
America you could easily been the
Bachelorette if Ari did things
differently
she giving no [ __ ] with her hair in a
bun I'm with her no totally and like
Becca coming in like full glam she it
was actually really funny you know what
juxtaposition of like her in a bikini
not giving a [ __ ] with her in a bun and
Becca
like literally thirsting with her
sandals in her hand and her romper which
was really [ __ ] cute
I've been following along on Garrett and
Becca's journey into the real world and
have to say I'm kind of here for them
I'm kind of here for them to they're
doing very normal things they're like
and they're not Thursdays doing every
web show
no offense like they just they did GMA
and then yeah and they took their
paparazzi pictures and now they're
looking Boston partying good for that
with their actual friends and like at
the Gansevoort and they're doing
everything right and I think that
they're very girl she seems so happy you
can always tell it's weird when like a
couple like stays in New York and like
does every press there offer and then I
takes advantage of everything like no
they've been hiding for so long now they
want to live real life like I don't know
who was I think was maybe Rachel and
Brian they literally did one thing and
then went to Dallas and like never left
like thank you well that's just not what
normal people do I agree
but then like making Vanessa are like
thirsting on the street taking paparazzi
pictures like something's up with your
new saline bag that you want right when
you're like doing anything to not be
alone with your significant other like
after the show like you've just spent
months apart from your fiance now you
can finally shout it to the world don't
you want to do that and you can tell
like every picture of Becca and get like
a he literally can't stop touching her
it's so cute it's so cute I'm here for
them I'm not here for paradise but I'm
gonna give it I'm gonna give it time but
you got to bring in some new guys we
need Conor no we need some old-school
guys it's like um these new guys were
like so weeny so we need so thirsty and
like we need like Blake like that's just
the pity of paradise it's like the real
strong guys like don't get to go because
yeah they're apparently too heartbroken
and then we're just left with the
thirsty ones who were eliminated early
because they were thirsty and now we're
watching more thirst and now you're
quenching their thirst by keeping them
on TV
it is a non-stop cycle of thirst
quenching and gonna self-destruct soon
we've been saying that forever right it
already it's like this is proof that it
is self-destructing because the formula
about certain paradise is genius like
when they first came out with it the
first two three seasons were just so
like I was so dare you know not anymore
no and I think the girls are better
about hiding their thirst which is why
they they see they're more palatable to
us yeah but the guys in there and
they're shirtless pictures on Instagram
and their inspirational quotes as a
caption like next next is that all we
have to say that is all we have to say
just friendly reminder noon is a big
announcement go to our Instagram camp
those tickets are available at the link
in our bio and Instagram password is
premium and so if I can be excited like
literally it's what I think about when I
go to sleep at night like all the
activities me too I need to do a whole
Amazon list of its like items I'll need
for camp toast so I'm definitely gonna
need some extra deodorant maybe some
like a portable fan I need some Sophie
shorts I need some biker shorts like
that's a so camp I know I also need
sneakers because I literally do not own
a single pair of sneakers you should get
all birds they're really comfortable
done anyways we'll see you all the
cantos were so excited keep our
Instagram at noon and we will be back
tomorrow with another amazing worldly
well-rounded episode of the morning
toast thank you guys so much for tuning
in it has been absolutely amazing
spending our morning with you the
morning toast is the Millennial morning
show we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube and
Facebook so make sure you subscribe to
us
YouTube give this video a thumbs up and
make sure you like us on Facebook and
then we're also available for those
commuters in the podcast app at the
morni toast also on soundcloud if you've
an android so make sure to subscribe
over there I think that's all I have to
say bye bye
you